also man sieht natürlich einkaufen und
man kauft einen natürlich stellen wir
fest dass kinopreise oder stückweise
teurer werden aber solange man das
selber immer noch tragen kann dann
drückt man das weg und damit einer kasse
steht man sich die menschen um sich
herum und dann ist ja erst noch eine
person davor und dann sehen sie eine
alte dame bezahlen ja zwischen 87 und
sie stellen auf einmal fest wie sie halt
nicht
bezahlen kann die sie nach ihrem
kleingeld wühlt und das hätte ich mehr
hat und sagt denn auch was können sie
was sie verzichten hand und geht das
brot und bildausschnitt zurück dann
sehen sie die alte dame weglaufen ich
kann ja nun schon nur im landtag
sprechen den abgeordneten häusern und
der bundestag aber wissen sie kappte
hier für unsere politik hat vollkommen
die bodenhaftung verloren hat vollkommen
die überblick verloren und ja wir können
alle weniger duschen aber fakt ist
vorbilder zu sein bedeutet auch
vorbildlich verhalten wenn ihr opfer und
um währungen von menschen in unserem
land fordert dann müsst ihr bei euch
anfang wenn eines nicht vergessen die
würde des menschen ist unantastbar und
das gilt nicht nur für reiche menschen
sondern für jeden bürger in unserem land